und jetzt hoffe ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 9 erste beratung ist
von den frank koalitionsfraktionen
eingebrachten gesetzentwurfs zur
fortgeltung der die epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite betreffenden
regelungen für die aussprache wurde eine
dauer von 60 minuten beschlossen die
aussprache und öffne ich unterteile das
wort der kollegin karin markt cdu/csu
[Applaus]
präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen auch in dieser woche wurde viel
über die beteiligung des parlaments bei
entscheidungen über die pandemische lage
gesprochen
und deswegen ist es mir heute besonders
wichtig und ich richte mich da jetzt
ausdrücklich an die fdp kollegen und an
die kollegen von den linken
dieses gesetz zur fortgeltung der
epidemischen lage ist nicht umsonst eine
parlaments initiative das ist unser
gesetzentwurf
wir abgeordnete aus der koalition
bringen diesen entwurf ein
wir abgeordnete wollen und werden wenn
es weiterhin notwendig sein sollte
künftig alle drei monate hier in diesem
parlament über das bestehen und
gegebenenfalls auch über das weitere
fortgehen der epidemischen lage
beschließen und entscheiden
wir abgeordnete stellen hier und heute
klar dass alle für den pandemiefall
notwendigen regelungen ausschließlich an
diesen unseren beschluss geknüpft werden
und wir werden diesen beschluss über die
fortgeltung dieser epidemischen lage mit
dem abschluss der beratung zu diesem
gesetz im märz erneut fassen warum ist
es so nur ist es notwendig darüber haben
wir diese woche ausführlich diskutiert
sollten nach weiteren
monaten also im juni keine weiteren
verlängerung notwendig seien dann
entscheiden wir hier im parlament gilt
die epidemische das entscheiden wir hier
im parlament und ángel die epidemische
lage aufgehoben und mit ihr alle für die
pandemie relevanten
verordnungsermächtigung und
rechtsverordnung und um sicherzustellen
dass die pandemie relevanten regelungen
künftig nur noch parallel zur
epidemischen lage bestehen werden wir
alle starren fristen die jetzt bestehen
zum 31
23 21 oder 2022 streichen
übrigens das was sie besonders ärgert
können dann auch die regelung die
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin
treffen nur auf der grundlage unseres
beschlusses über das ford geltende
pandemischen lage überhaupt rechts
wirksamkeit entfalten
kurz wir regeln das wesentliche wir
setzen den rahmen und die details regeln
die regierungen meine damen und herren
kolleginnen und kollegen vor knapp einem
jahr im märz haben wir die epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite
festgestellt und ihr fortbestehen im
november beschlossen
ich konnte mir damals nicht vorstellen
dass wir ein jahr später heute diese
regelungen noch brauchen würden jetzt
sinkt die zahl der neuansteckungen
ermutigende art und weise auf den
intensivstationen unseres landes
befinden sich 2000 patienten weniger als
noch vor vier wochen
aber leider immer noch 1000 mehr als im
frühjahr
und es macht uns sorgen weil wir wissen
dass der virus auf gefährliche art
mutiert ist die englische variante zum
beispiel es um 50% ansteckender als die
bisher bekannte variante und es hat
natürlich extreme auswirkungen auf die
zahl der neuansteckungen gleichzeitig
wir sind alle in union
wahlkreisabgeordnete wissen wir um die
stimmung im land den stresstest hat ja
bisher nicht nur unser gesundheitssystem
mit seinen akteuren gut bestanden
herzlichen dank an alle
aber der dank gilt gleichermaßen für die
menschen im land auch sie alle haben
durchgehalten große leistung auch da
herzlichen dank viele viele von ihnen
befürworten auch weiterhin harte
maßnahmen die die instanzen weiter
senken und damit vor allem die mutation
jetzt an der verbreitung hindern
und trotzdem auch ich erhalte die anrufe
und e mails sehen sich die mehrheit
unserer bürgerinnen und bürger nach
lockerung und nicht nur jetzt in dieser
volatilen lage brauchen wir einen
sicheren rechtsrahmen sondern vor allem
auch für die zukunft viele
rechtliche regelung haben wir in dieser
corona zeit neu entworfen und angepasst
das föderale zusammenwirkung hat auch im
infektionsschutz eine ganz neue
bedeutung gefunden
deshalb ist es richtig und wichtig dass
wir diese rechtlichen regelungen und
ihre wirkung insgesamt wie wir jetzt im
rahmen der pandemie getroffen haben
analysieren und überprüfen lassen und
diese evaluierung geben wir auf bis zum
31 dezember diesen jahres wir meinen
dass es ein interdisziplinäres
forschungs gremium sein muss wir können
uns vorstellen dass dies die leopoldina
ist und wir wollen daraus dann die
notwendigen schlüsse ziehen für das
vorgehen in der pandemie in künftigen
lagern und natürlich für womöglich das
infektionsschutzgesetz aber wollen wir
und wir wollen weiter auch die impf
ziele wie zum beispiel die reduktion
tödlicher oder schwere
krankheitsverläufe oder die
aufrechterhaltung zentrale staatliche
funktionen in das infektionsschutzgesetz
aufnehmen
übrigens wir sind auch davon überzeugt
dass die priorisierung im rahmen einer
rechtsverordnung der anz eine
ausreichende rechtliche grundlage hat
höchst vorsorglich nehmen wir die impf
ziele in das infektionsschutzgesetz auf
gleichzeitig legen wir fest dass
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
und die entsprechenden rechtsverordnung
nicht nur die impf ziele beachten müssen
wir geben die priorisierung kriterien
ausdrücklich vor und wir haben beide
besondere regelungen im gesetz vor da
geht es vor allem um die pflege um die
weiterführung von schutzschirmen wir die
die ambulante pflege in stationäre
pflege betreffen aber auch die
pflegebedürftigen und ihre angehörigen
wir verlängern den rettungsschirm für
die niedergelassenen ärzte
selbstverständlich werden wir die
bedarfe im gesetzgebungsverfahren
ausführlich prüfen die regelung zum
kinderkrankengeld stehen
sie dürfen nicht vom versichertenstatus
abhängen meinen mir ich freue mich auf
die weiteren beratungen herzlichen dank
privat war das gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der unionsfraktion und sie
hat den gesetzentwurf der
koalitionsfraktionen hier vorgestellt
der den titel trägt fortgeltung der
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
es geht um die grundlage für weitere
entscheidungen rund um maßnahmen gegen
korona beziehungsweise hilfen wegen
corona und der nächste redner in dieser
debatte werde sein euro vj schlund aus
der fdp-fraktion hessen mitglied im
gesundheitsausschuss sehr guter
präsident werde kollegen management
bedeutet gemeinsames zielorientiertes
problem lösen und das ziel dieser
bundesregierung bestand letztes jahr
darin die produktionszahl auf 1,0 und
darunter zu halten
und da liegen wir ja augenblicklich auch
trotz dieses wissens arbeiten sie weiter
an der zementierung ihres komplett
versagens im management oder dem problem
lösen in der korona krise so zum
beispiel mitarbeiter aus allen bereichen
des gesundheitswesen arbeiten
tatsächlich am limit mit einem weiter so
und diesem gesetzesentwurf wenn sie sich
den genau anschauen ist ein
zusammenbruch der ambulanten
gesundheitsversorgung vorprogrammiert wo
zb bleiben die dringend nötige
fortsetzung der schutzmaßnahmen für die
niedergelassenen praxis praxen
wir geben ihnen jetzt schon die schuld
an der indirekten enteignung der
vertragsärzte und den verlust der freien
und unabhängigen beruflich kite meine
damen und herren
denn bei weiter sinkenden fallzahlen von
30 und mehr in den praxen kann man ein
ambulantes system nicht mehr betreiben
hätte man sich hier auch in anderen
bereichen auf die lösung der probleme in
dieser krise konzentrieren statt auf die
sitzung zweifelhafter teilweise
abenteuerliche projekte wir haben uns
die lok daumens in dieser form
weitergehen er sport geblieben
wir können es nicht mehr hinnehmen dass
ermächtigungen und grundrechts
einschränkung weiter unsere landschaft
hier beherrschen
eine lösung wäre dass auf die haster
management gewesen was wir genau heute
hier vor einem jahr gefordert haben was
es passiert nichts im ausschuss sagen
sie uns auch noch die fdp bringt doch
nicht sie macht nicht und wir bringen
sieben anträge ein haben sie es denn
nicht verstanden dass wir gemeinsam
arbeiten müssen haben sie das nicht
verstanden für unsere menschen da
draußen schaut man sich die ja schaut
man sich in diesem zusammenhang die
hopkins daten an
dann merken sie ganz schnell was hier
passiert denn der komplette lockdown den
wir hier betreiben hätte doch die korona
sterblichkeit herunterbringen müssen was
ist aber passiert im durchschnitt sind
die länder die keinen lockdown oder
nicht den lockdown in dieser form
gemacht haben liegt die sterblichkeit
von 0,05 prozent corona wurden auf die
gesamt bevölkerungszahl in deutschland
und in österreich ist das doppelt so
hoch ist denn dass das management was
wir brauchen für unsere menschen hier in
diesem land da fragt man sich zu recht
hat man hier alles richtig gemacht oder
ist auch mal die zeit gekommen fehler
einzugestehen
das sind sie dass meine damen und herren
sind sie die menschen in diesem land in
der tat schuldig deshalb appelliere ich
an sie diesen gesetzentwurf diesen
gesetzesentwurf über die fortführung der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite sofort zu beenden sofort von
der tagesordnung zu nehmen und durch
einen gesetzesentwurf zu ersetzen der
sich an einem raster konzept und den
drei säulen des pandemie managements
orientiert unter kontrolle eines
expertenrates den wir schon seit anfang
gefordert haben nur damit können die
maßnahmen beendet werden
der lock down ist sofort zu beenden die
pandemische lage ist sofort aufzuheben
meine damen und herren und meine damen
und herren
tun sie das bitte nicht für sich tun sie
das für die menschen dieses landes denn
die ertragen das alles nicht mehr meine
damen und herren
viele sind vom jobverlust bedroht
bedroht und fürchten um ihre existenz
die lebensmittelpreise steigen werden
viele in kurzarbeit sind oder gar kein
geld mehr kriegen hilfen bleiben aus
oder werden zu spät gezahlt die zahl der
psychisch kranken kindern hat sich in
der zweiten lok dauern fast verdoppelt
wenn sie schon nichts für sicht nur in
meinen damen und herren dann tun sie es
wenigstens für unsere kinder denn sie
sind das wertvollste was wir besitzen
vielen dank
so wie schlund für die aif die fraktion
und mit dem stand oder mit der
erkenntnis dass die jetzige lage nicht
gefährliches hat die afg ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal im parlament
nächste rednerin ist hilde mattheis aus
der spd fraktion
sie ist mitglied im gesundheitsausschuss
und kollegen
ich glaube wir gehen heute in die
debatte mit zuversicht aber auch mit
vorsicht zuversicht weil die zahlen
sinken und maßnahmen greifen
vorsicht weil uns das nicht ausreicht
und weil wir die bevölkerung schützen
und die akzeptanz ist da und die
transparenz müssen wir herstellen
deswegen wir als parlament haben hier
heute den auftrag die pandemische lage
wieder für weiter festzustellen und zu
sagen lasst uns noch drei monate alle
verordnungen rechtsverordnungen
weitergelten lassen und dann hier im
parlament wieder diskutieren wie die
situation ist und wie die lockerung
womöglich auch greifen können über das
hinaus was er jetzt am mittwoch schon
miteinander besprochen worden ist
ich glaube und das ist die richtung in
die afg durch behauptungen die seit
einem jahr aufgestellt werden
durch die wiederholung von behauptungen
werden diese nicht zu fakten sondern die
fakten liegen auf dem tisch und wir
reagieren als parlament und auch ich
habe mir vor einem jahr nicht vorstellen
wollen dass wir diese fortsetzung hier
beschließen müssen aber ich denke auch
dass wir als gesundheitspolitiker als
rechtspolitiker als mitglieder hier im
parlament und dermaßen oft mit dieser
situation beschäftigen und meistens sind
wir gesundheitspolitiker die ersten
geräten hier im parlament
die letzten die hier gehen weil einfach
die situation so ist und mit diesem mit
diesem gesetz dass wir die fortgeltung
hier heute beschließen nehmen wir für
uns in anspruch dass wir uns sehr wohl
kritisch auseinandersetzen und vor allen
dingen auch jeden punkt einzeln ganz
klar immer wieder beleuchten und
hinterfragen und unserer verantwortung
bewusst sind deshalb die dreimonatige
fortsetzung dieser situation stellt uns
vor die aufgabe nicht nur die maßnahmen
immer zu hinterfragen sondern auch
maßnahmen zu konkretisieren das haben
wir mit der impfstrategie und mit der
festlegung weiterer punkte im
infektionsschutzgesetz und auch im sgb 5
gemacht wir haben dem rechnung getragen
was die diskussion und die debatte uns
aufgegeben haben
wir haben diese konkretisierung was die
einzelnen bevölkerungsgruppen anbelangt
hier niedergeschrieben also wir
schreiben nicht nur einfach fort sondern
wir entwickeln fort und das ist auch
unser auftrag und damit glaube ich haben
wir dem rechnung getragen was auch von
oppositionsseite an uns herangetragen
worden ist was wir in anhörungen
diskutiert haben was wir unter uns
diskutiert haben dass es nämlich darum
geht alles auch rechts fest zu machen
und die evaluierung ist einer der
wichtigen punkte den wir als
spd-fraktion immer wieder auch gesagt
haben uns geht das nicht weiter
da wird mein kollege noch die
ausführungen machen
es geht uns nicht weit genug wir hätten
das infektionsschutzgesetz gerne
befristet weil wir glauben dass wir die
lehren aus corona auch im
infektionsschutzgesetz niederschreiben
müssen aber die evaluierung gibt uns die
chance gibt dem nächsten parlament die
chance dass alles aus distanz noch
einmal richtig anzupacken und zu sagen
was brauchen wir denn im
infektionsschutzgesetz das ja als wir es
hier im parlament vor etlichen jahren
beschlossen haben in seiner reichweite
noch gar nicht abgesehen werden konnte
sondern was jetzt einfach auch die
grundlage für entscheidungen und
maßnahmen ist das müssen wir uns
angucken und dafür sind wir auch da und
deshalb sage ich das ist einer der
wichtigen punkte die evaluierung und was
uns angeht wir würden neben der enz
strategie die konkretisierung auch was
die test strategie anbelangt gerne hier
eintragen und gerne diskutieren dafür
bleibt die parlamentarische debatte
dafür bleibt auch die anhörung dass wir
das womöglich noch einmal nach schärfen
denn eines ist klar wir ruhen uns hier
nicht aus sondern wir reagieren und wir
wollen dass die bevölkerung auch den
eindruck hat und das ist glaube ich auch
unser anspruch den wir an uns selbst
haben dass wir hier das nicht
leichtfertig machen sondern dass wir auf
jeden fall mit der wissenschaft mit den
praktikern auch vor ort in den kliniken
den ständigen austausch haben und auch
reflektieren was wir hier machen und
daher bitte ich dass wir offen ihnen die
beratungen reingehen
und dass wir auch die transparenz
herstellen
das klar ist dass wir hier nicht einfach
durch fingerschnippen sondern dass wir
klar auch auf der grundlage einer
wissenschaftlichen debatte unsere
entscheidungen treffen
ich bedanke mich fürs zuhören sagt hilde
mattheis aus der spd fraktion in dieser
ersten beratung eines gesetzentwurfs der
koalition zur fortgeltung der
epidemischen lage der aber noch einige
punkte mehr enthält als die reine zeit
definition dieser notlage nächste
rednerin in dieser debatte ist christine
aschenberg-dugnus die
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der fdp
versicherung präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen im vorliegenden
gesetzesentwurf werden erstmalig im
ziele festgelegt das begrüßen wir
außerordentlich liebe karin maag du hast
ja das extra an die fdp gerichtet
übrigens haben wir genau das in unserem
gesetzentwurf gefordert die koalition
ist es insofern auch gefolgt und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der großen
koalition das können sie öfter machen
als service opposition gehen wir gerne
in vorleistung
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite soll jetzt alle drei monate
vom deutschen bundestag neu festgestellt
werden gut so wir haben zwar in unserem
antrag vom letzten jahr alle zwei monate
gefordert und beantragt aber geschenkt
aber meine damen und herren ich frage
mich immer wieder warum sie sich
eigentlich so standhaft weigern bei der
impf priorisierung per verordnung die
zustimmung des deutschen bundestages
einzuholen denn das ist das was wir
verlangen und was notwendig ist denn bei
der verteilung des impfstoffes
es sich doch ganz zweifelsfrei um einen
tiefgreifenden grundrechtseingriff ist
es deshalb nicht nur die aufgabe es ist
die pflicht des deutschen bundestages
diese wesentlichen entscheidungen hier
selbst zu treffen meine damen und herren
und ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen
die frage der impf priorisierung muss
hier getroffen werden und eben nicht per
verordnung vom ministerium
deswegen hoffe ich dass sie ihr gesetz
noch nachbessern und diesen
verfassungswidrigen zustand beenden
meine damen und herren es hilft ihnen
auch nicht im parlament die epidemische
lage zu beschließen und dann sozusagen
eine dreimonatige dauer genehmigung für
alle verordnungen zu haben
eine blankovollmacht für alle
verordnungen des ministers ist nicht
zulässig meine damen und herren wir
wollen eben nicht diese dauer
genehmigung haben und jetzt wird es ja
noch schöner ersparen
jetzt die mpk hat ja jetzt den minister
aufgefordert ein prüfauftrag wurde ihm
sozusagen erteilt die impf priorisierung
zugunsten der lehrer und erzieher zu
ändern also die mpk entscheidet da jetzt
etwas was herr minister prüfen soll das
finde ich schon ein bisschen sehr
eigenartig meine damen und herren wir
das ist gegen das parlament genau so ist
es ich wollte nicht ganz so hart
formulierung aber das ist ein unding
meine damen und herren es geht ja gar
nicht darum ob lehrer oder erzieher
zuerst geimpft werden da sind wir ja
ganz bei ihnen
aber das kann doch nicht entschieden
werden von einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz oder im
ministerium das gehört eindeutig in die
zuständigkeit des deutschen bundestages
meine damen und herren ich komme jetzt
zu den notwendigen verlängerung der
schutzschirme leider zu unserem großen
bedauern wurde die nicht eins zu eins
verlängert ich wurde in der letzten
woche von mehreren kinder ärzten
angesprochen die beklagen dass der
rettungsschirm in der jetzigen form eben
nicht geeignet ist
ihre existenziellen nöte abzumildern und
das betrifft leider auch anderer
arztgruppen da muss dringend
nachgebessert werden
denn nicht nur kinder er hat sie sondern
auch alle anderen fachärzte und anderen
gruppen sind jetzt in der besonderen
situation ganz ganz wichtig meine damen
und herren in der vorliegenden form ist
der schutzschirm leider nicht geeignet
die nöte der gesundheits akteure zu
kompensieren denn zum beispiel
physiotherapeuten zahnärzte hebammen um
nur einige zu nennen sind hier überhaupt
nicht aufgeführt aber dazu wird mein
kollege schönburg sich noch äußern
meine damen und herren zum schluss bitte
noch muss ich was loswerden was mich
richtig geärgert hat sie haben lässt
diese woche wieder einmal die chance
verpasst den bürgerinnen und bürgern den
unternehmern den kulturschaffenden
planbarkeit und perspektive zu
verschaffen
ein stufenplan ist dringend erforderlich
er muss verständlich er muss
nachvollziehbar sein nach klaren wenn
dann regeln sowie unser antrag den wir
am mittwoch eingebracht haben ich freue
mich auf die beratung und bedanke mich
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
danke
[Applaus]
dr achim keßler die linke ist der
nächste redner der präsident ein sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich teile die
befürchtungen der bundeskanzlerin dass
uns die mutation des corona virus noch
viel unheil bringen werden
erstens sind sie ansteckender und
zweitens verringern sie zum teil sogar
die wirkung der impfung in deutschland
geht zwar die gesamtzahl der neu
infektionen zurück aber die zahl der
infektionen mit den mutationen steigt
sprunghaft an
wir können nicht mehr davon ausgehen
dass mit 2x an alles erledigt ist
meine damen und herren ich befürchte
dass uns die pandemie noch lange
begleiten wird
wir brauchen deshalb dringend eine
langfristig angelegte strategie zur
bekämpfung der pandemie die
bundesregierung fährt seit einem jahr
auf sicht das können wir uns nicht
länger leisten
wir müssen schon jetzt vorkehrungen
treffen dass der impfstoff laufend
angepasst wird und wir müssen alle
möglichkeiten ausschöpfen damit
impfstoffe an möglichst vielen
produktions orten weltweit hergestellt
werden können es stimmt der aufbau von
produktion dauert monate
aber ich fürchte wir werden diese
produktionsstätten angesichts der
mutation noch lange brauchen
der gesundheitsminister trägt seit drei
monaten vor welche schwierigkeiten mit
dem aufbau von produktionsstandorten
verbunden sind diese schwierigkeiten
werden aber durch nichtstun nicht
weniger und ich fordere sie auf hören
sie endlich auf wertvolle zeit
verstreichen zu lassen handeln sie
endlich heben sie die patente für die
impfstoffe frei damit sie überall
weltweit produziert werden
die rechtlichen möglichkeiten dazu haben
sie und die ethische verantwortung erst
recht werden sie dieser verantwortung
endlich gerecht dion tag und preise
erhielten aus steuermitteln 375
millionen für die impfstoffentwicklung
und die klinischen studien der us
konzern pfizer erwartet aus dem
impfstoff einen umsatz von 15 milliarden
dollar pfizer und biontech zusammen habe
eine gewinn erwartung durch die
impfstoffe von vier milliarden euro
ein unternehmerisches risiko gibt es
praktisch nicht weil es hier
abnahmegarantien gibt und jetzt verlangt
die ontrack erneut 400 millionen euro
zusätzlich für den aufbau zusätzlicher
produktionskapazitäten
meine damen und herren diese forderung
offenbart eine schamlose profit gier in
einer situation in der die ganze welt
von einer pandemie und ihren
gesundheitlichen sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen folgen gedroht wird
und es ist das offene eingeständnis dass
die pharmaindustrie mit dem aufbau der
erforderlichen produktionskapazitäten
überfordert ist
meine damen und herren auch angesichts
der neuen milliarden euro die sie für
die beschaffung von impfstoffen
bereitgestellt haben muss die produktion
von impfstoffen jetzt unter staatliche
kontrolle gestellt wird es hat sich
deutlich gezeigt dass profitstreben
nicht der geeignete antrieb ist um eine
pandemie zu bewältigen
aber statt auf der grundlage einer durch
den bundestag legitimierten strategie
entschlossen zu handeln
legen sie uns erneut einen gesetzentwurf
vor mit dem der bundestag regelungs
kompetenzen an die bundesregierung
abgibt nehmen sie den präsidenten des
bundesverfassungsgerichts stefan herbert
ernst er sagt genau wie wir seit monaten
die wesentlichen entscheidungen
durch das parlament getroffen werden die
linke stets zu unserer demokratischen
verfassung und deshalb lehnen wir ihren
gesetzentwurf ab je länger die partie
dauerte desto mehr verletzen sie das
demokratieprinzip
ich fordere sie auf beenden sie diese
zerstörerische politik die das vertrauen
in unseren staat untergräbt
sehr geehrte damen und herren von der
regierungsfraktion von den
regierungsfraktionen ich frage wovor
haben sie angst dass sie sich so
standhaft weigern die verantwortung in
dieser krise selbst zu übernehmen
hören sie auf sich hinter einer
kanzlerin und einem einer
bundesregierung zu verstecken
die ein völliges im chaos angerichtet
haben die entscheidungen müssen wieder
in den bundestag zurück geholt werden
damit wir endlich handlungsfähig werden
im ersten entwurf des gesetzes war noch
drei milliarden euro zuschuss für die
pflegeversicherung vorgesehen
davon ist jetzt nur noch eine
verordnungsermächtigung übrig dass die
bundesregierung der pflegeversicherung
einen zuschuss geben kann
damit überschreiten sie endgültig die
verfassungsrechtlichen grenzen denn das
haushaltsrecht ist das wichtigste recht
des bundestages und sie verunsichern die
vielen vielen menschen mit pflegebedarf
denen sie vollmundig eine begrenzung
ihrer eigenen anteile versprochen haben
weil sie zur armutsfalle für die
menschen mit pflege darf und ihre
angehörigen geworden angeordnet worden
sind diese politik der sozialen kälte
lehnt die linke ab und deshalb auch
ihren gesetzentwurf ich bedanke mich für
achim kessler war das der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der
linksfraktion der bundestag diskutiert
nach wie vor über einen gesetzentwurf
der koalition zur fortgeltung der
epidemischen lage der allerdings auch
eine reihe anderer punkte enthält zum
beispiel etwa was die impfverordnung
angeht nächste rednerin ist kordula
schulz asche in der fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen sprecherin für pflege und
altenpolitik
herr präsident meine damen und herren
die zahlreichen debatten hier im
bundestag allein in dieser woche zeigen
dass sie carola pandemie nach wie vor
unser aller leben bestimmt dass die lage
ernst ist und gleichzeitig die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu nehmenden
wirbel und der krise müde werden und wir
alle sehen uns nach normalität und einer
perspektive aus dieser krise aber so
ehrlich müssen wir auch sein
wir sind noch nicht über den berg und
deswegen ist ein weiteres gesetz zur
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
notwendig und ich begrüße es
ausdrücklich dass jetzt die
regierungsfraktionen nun nicht allein
nur die regierung hier die initiative
übernommen hat aber meine damen und
herren was sie uns hier vorgelegt haben
ist leider inhaltlich wenig von dem zu
unterscheiden was wir bisher gesehen
haben
es ist und das ist nach wie vor das
problem sie sind einfach nicht bereit
aus den bisherigen erfahrungen zu lernen
oder sie können es nicht und das ist der
größte fehler den man dieser pandemie
machen kann
meine damen und herren wir brauchen
klarheit über die rechtsgrundlage ist es
auch während einer pandemie notwendig
die einschränkung der freiheitsrechte
gerade in der pandemie zu begründen wenn
sie und das sind sie nur wenn sie bereit
demokratisch legitimiert sind durch
bundestag und bundesrat als
verfassungsmäßige organisationen
sie müssen wir dringend nachbessern denn
breite demokratische legitimation ist
auch die voraussetzung der akzeptanz von
freiheitseinschränkende maßnahmen und
weiter meine damen und herren in einer
demokratie muss das krisen-management
nachvollziehbar
vorausschauend und angemessen sein von
der regierung gibt es in drei wochen
rhythmus autoritäre ansagen und auch
jetzt in der vorlage der
regierungsfraktionen finden wir keine
strategie die den weg durch und aus der
krise aufzeigen würde
wir brauchen aber meine damen und herren
sonst werden wir es nicht schaffen das
überzeugte mitmachen der bevölkerung
beim überwinden der krise und deswegen
halten es für nötig dass wir einen
stufenplan für den weg die perspektive
aus dieser pandemie mit einheitlichkeit
von regeln bundesweit und anpassung an
das jeweilige infektionsgeschehen
regional erhalten und wann können
schulen restaurants theater wegen meiner
auf friseursalons wieder öffnen und
unter welchen bedingungen müssen sie
eventuell auch wieder schließen für
bestimmte zeiten das brauchen wir doch
als sicherheit als information die für
die menschen so wichtig ist
seit monaten fordern wir und die
regierung und jetzt auch die
regierungsfraktionen verweigern einen
interdisziplinären wissenschaftlichen
pandemie rat der sich zusammensetzt aus
unterschiedlichen wissenschaften ja aus
virologen aus medizinern aber auch aus
und von sozialwissenschaftlern von
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern von
pädagogik wissenschaftlern wir brauchen
ein breites spektrum von
wissenschaftlern die die maßnahmen
erarbeiten und vorschlagen die während
der durchführung ihrer wirksamkeit
bewerten das macht doch im moment keiner
und der dann entsprechende anpassung
empfiehlt das ist die aufgabe eines
pandemie rat den sie seit monaten
verweigern und was sie jetzt vorliegen
in diesem gesetzentwurf ist wirklich es
kaum geglaubt aber es ist eine
halbherzige evaluierung bis zum jahre
2022 wir brauchen aber solche
erkenntnisse jetzt um die maßnahme
zu begründen und ich verstehe es einfach
nicht oder ich verstehe nicht warum sie
es nie verstehen wir müssen die
maßnahmen jetzt begründen und zwar
wissenschaftlich und interdisziplinär
die kommunikation dieser regierung in
dieser partie im panini gegenüber der
bevölkerung ist eine absolute
katastrophe
und das muss sich endlich ändern und es
sind viele offene fragen nach wie vor
die frage wo sind die produktions
anreize zum beispiel für antigen hättest
für den häuslichen gebrauch eine
wichtige voraussetzung um den
öffentlichen raum wieder zu öffnen wo es
die gesetzliche grundlage für die impf
priorisierung wie ist der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts und der
präsident des sozialgerichts des
sozialgerichts fordern und meine damen
und herren für pflegeeinrichtungen
drohend und mit ihrer jetzigen
gesetzentwurf sogar verschlechterungen
ja meine damen und herren wir haben
gesehen ältere menschen nicht nur aber
vor allem ältere menschen sind von
dieser pandemie betroffen und ihre
angehörigen und die einrichtungen in
denen sie gepflegt werden und die
hausärztinnen und hausärzte denen diese
einrichtung gegangen sind und ihre
patienten weiter versorgt haben
und es war gut dass die
pflegeeinrichtungen in den
rettungsschirm aufgenommen worden und es
ist gut dass die priorisierung mit dem
impfen in diesen einrichtungen begonnen
hat aber meine damen und herren wir
wissen noch nichts über die folgeschäden
und nun drohte mit diesem gesetzentwurf
sogar mindereinnahmen denn die
einrichtungen drohen jetzt aus dem
rettungsschirm haus zu fallen haben zum
teil der stände bis zu 30 prozent
denn sie befürchten und meine damen und
herren wir sollten die chance lieber
nutzen die heime für die zukunft besser
aufzustellen damit sie krisenfester
werden und damit nicht so viele menschen
in diesen einrichtungen tatsächlich auch
opfer einer pandemie werden
hermanis ersparen wir haben ein jahr
lang versucht bewusst versucht
konstruktive opposition zu sein denn in
einer krise passieren fehler und vor
allem auch in einer solchen dynamischen
krise aber fehler müssen auch benannt
und korrigiert werden aber sie
wiederholen die alten fehler und damit
verspielen sie das notwendige vertrauen
der menschen in diese krise legen sie
einen wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen
basierenden perspektiven stufenplan vor
und schaffen sie die
verfassungsrechtlichen grundlagen da
vielleicht danken für aufmerksamkeit
kordula schulz-asche sprecherin für
pflege und altenpolitik in der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen zum schluss noch
mit anmerkungen direkt in richtung des
bundesgesundheitsministers der auch
heute wieder übrigens eine
pressekonferenz geben wird zum stand der
dinge
circa 10 uhr 15 sind wir dann live dabei
der nächste redner hier im plenum ist
thorsten frei stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unionsfraktion sehr
geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist in der
tat so als wir uns vor knapp einem jahr
das erste mal mit den rechtlichen
grundlagen zur bekämpfung der kogit 19
pandemie beschäftigt haben
da ging es um gesetze und verordnungen
die hatten fristen bis ende juni bis
september bis jahresende manchmal auch
der 31 märz 2021 das ist ein
wesentlicher grund warum wir jetzt heute
hier zu diesem thema zusammen kommen es
waren fristen zu zeiten wo wir uns
glaube ich nicht hätten vorstellen
können dass wir ein knappes jahr später
noch mitten in dieser pandemie
drinstecken dass wir 60 tausend tote
später sind und mit großen
herausforderungen in gesundheitlicher in
gesellschaftlicher sozialer aber auch
ökonomischer art befasst
und deshalb ist es notwendig sich immer
wieder auch mit den rechtlichen
grundlagen zu befassen
ich will das ganz offen sagen ich habe
sehr aufmerksam auch den rednerinnen und
redner der oppositionsfraktionen
zugehört ich habe auch da viel kluges
gehört nicht nur aber da war auch kluges
dabei und deswegen will ich an dieser
stelle einfach sagen sie sollten nie
auch an dieser stelle nicht unterstellen
dass die regierungsfraktionen oder auch
die bundesregierung nicht bereit wäre
aus situationen und entwicklungen zu
lernen und daraus die notwendigen
schlüsse zu ziehen das tun wir das haben
wir in den vergangenen
gesetzgebungsprozesses bewiesen
beispielsweise als es um das dritte
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz gehen und es
werden wir auch in diesem verfahren wird
doch beweisen und ich sage ihnen
ausdrücklich zu wir sind daran
interessiert auch mit den
oppositionsfraktionen gemeinsam zu
erörtern wie wir es schaffen können
für diese maßnahmen eine möglichst
breite mehrheit hier im parlament zu
schaffen das ist unser ziel erklärte die
kollegin nötig eine zwischenfrage
stellen bitteschön ja vielen dank herr
kollege frei dass sie die frage zu
lasten der minister ergreift er nicht
das wort also muss ich mich an sie
wenden
aber das mache ich natürlich auch sehr
gerne sie haben gerade gesagt dass sie
aus den fehlern lernen wollen und
verbesserungen nun habe ich eine ganz
konkrete frage wie sie das einschätzen
die situation die auch heute wieder in
der tagesschau berichtet wird dass die
impf priorisierung die reihenfolge
häufig verletzt wurde mit der kleinen
ausrede da sind ja impfdosen übrig
geblieben
aber man weiß von vielen fällen das
schon vor beginn der impfung landräte
bürgermeister sich haben impfen lassen
dass auch ja einfach gesagt wo demnächst
was übriggeblieben lass mal schnell
impfen
und wir haben am mittwoch im ausschuss
mit dem minister darüber gesprochen und
er hat gesagt da hat man
keine rechtlichen handhabungen um das zu
ich sag mal zu bestrafen oder wie auch
immer ist das zb aus ihrer sicht
einfallen oder ein feld auf dem mann zu
veränderungen kommen müsste wenn ja wie
würden sie das vorschlagen und wenn nein
warum nicht
sehen sie frau kollegin lötzsch das ist
ein ganz wesentlicher punkt warum wir
genau darauf achten müssen dass wir hier
im parlament die wesentlichen
grundsatzfragen die grundrechts relevant
sind selbst entscheiden und darüber
hinaus der bundesregierung oder in
diesem fall den bundesminister durch
verordnungsermächtigung die möglichkeit
geben spezifisch auf die
herausforderungen zu reagieren
wir tun das im übrigen auch mit diesem
gesetz das heute eingebracht wird und
wir schaffen damit die voraussetzungen
dass auf dieser grundlage aus
buchstabiert werden kann wie die impf
ziele und die impf priorisierungen ganz
konkret umgesetzt werden den fall den
sie beschreiben finde ich bedauerlich
das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich
finde ihn nicht nur bedauerlich er ist
dort wo es missbrauch gibt auch in
höchstem maße unsolidarisch und
natürlich auch maximal unklug das kann
man nicht anders formulieren
insbesondere dann wenn diejenigen die an
regeln mitarbeiten sie selber zu ihren
eigenen gunsten brechen ist es absolut
indiskutabel
aber ich glaube dass wir auf der
grundlage dieser grundsätze auch
flexibilität brauchen um sicherzustellen
dass im stoßen am ende eines tages nicht
ungenutzt in der ecke stehen bleiben und
deshalb kommt es darauf an dass man
durchaus auch definiert wie man in
solchen fällen umgeht und ich stelle mir
da beispielsweise polizistinnen und
polizisten vor die im streifendienst
sind die jederzeit erreichbar sind die
vor allen dingen im feuer stehen und
unmittelbar konfrontiert sind mit
situationen wo sie kontakten nicht
ausweichen können
dort müssen wir glaube ich mehr tun
schneller impfen und es ist eine
möglichkeit damit umzugehen
ich will mich im weiteren gerne auf die
grundsätzlichen juristischen bemerkungen
konzentrieren weil wir nachher noch gute
sehr sehr gute redner haben die die
übrigen aspekte dieses gesetzes
beleuchten können
ich kann beispielsweise nicht verstehen
warum man hier bemängelt dass die
evaluierungs vorschrift die wir ins
gesetz rein nehmen nicht stark genug
sein dass sie zu langwierig sein warum
denn eigentlich tun sie doch nicht so
als ob sich nicht die bundesregierung
die bundestagsfraktionen die regierungs
wie die oppositionsfraktionen permanent
auch wissenschaftlichen rat einholen und
zwar nicht nur von virologen und
epidemiologen sondern natürlich
interdisziplinär was kann falsch daran
sein dass wir neben der jederzeitigen
kontrolle und überarbeitung dessen was
wir tun auch längerfristig in den
nächsten zwölf monaten externen
wissenschaftlichen rat einholen dazu
muss sich die bundesregierung verhalten
und dazu muss ich auch dieses parlament
verhalten das ist doch ganz
selbstverständlich frau kollegin
rottmann vom bündnis wollen die grünen
würden auch gerne eine zwischenfrage
stellen sehr gerne herr präsident dass
sie die zwischenfrage zu lassen
ich habe also sie sagen ist doch gut
dass wir evaluieren ich habe eine
einzige frage wir haben die ganze zeit
erzählt dass die inzidenz werte dazu
dienen die nachverfolgbarkeit von
kontakten in den gesundheitsämtern zu
ermöglichen
der wert ab dem die nachverfolgbarkeit
nicht mehr funktioniert ändert sich aber
ständig warum brauchen wir jetzt eine
studie warum können wir nicht nach einem
jahr erklären wie sind die kapazitäten
in den deutschen gesundheitsämtern wie
viele kontakte können die ab welcher
incidents nachverfolgen und darauf einen
stufenplan aufsetzen warum ist das nach
einem die
gar nicht möglich das ist niemandem zu
erklären frau kollegin dr rottmann
zunächst einmal ist es so dass wir
natürlich in den vergangenen monaten
auch vieles dafür unternommen haben dass
die kompetenzen und möglichkeiten im
staatlichen gesundheitswesen verbessert
wird und dass nachverfolgung auch unter
besseren umständen gewährleistet werden
kann
der zweite punkt wo liegt die
schwierigkeit die schwierigkeit liegt
auch darin dass wir uns nicht nur mit
einem virus zu tun haben sondern
zunehmend auch mit mutationen die über
eine höhere infektiosität verfügen die
wir nicht am ende einschätzen können und
wo wir in der großen gefahr stehen dass
diese mutanten auch in deutschland wie
wir sie in anderen ländern schon erlebt
haben die überhand gewinnen können und
die dritte frage die sie gestellt haben
frau dr rottmann warum kann man nicht
auf diesen instanzen aufbauend einen
stufen oder einen perspektiv plan
entwickeln muss man sagen dass wir das
im grunde genommen im paragrafen 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ja bereits
haben wir haben dort als parlament klar
definiert ab welchen instanzen und
möglicherweise zusätzlichen indikationen
welche maßnahmen durch die bundes- und
die landesregierungen möglich sind das
haben wir gemacht ich will nicht
ausschliessen frau dr rottmann dass wir
im parlamentarischen verfahren auch dazu
kommen dass noch etwas näher aus zu
buchstabieren weil sie mit den
grundlegenden anliegen ja recht haben
dass wir perspektiven für die menschen
brauchen nachvollziehbarkeit das ist
richtig und notwendig und deswegen
können wir uns über solche fragen auch
im parlamentarischen verfahren
unterhalten
also frau kollegin hasselmann natürlich
tun wir das alles jetzt wir spielen doch
nicht auf zeit ganz im gegenteil wir
sind daran interessiert dass die dinge
gut gelöst werden und das sind wir ich
hab's schon gesagt auch ein
zusammenarbeit interessiert ich will
noch zwei aspekte kurz erwähnen das eine
ist wir nehmen die doppelten und
dreifachen netze aus dem gesetz raus wir
haben ja vorschriften im
infektionsschutzgesetz die sind
ausschließlich aus die auf die kurve 19
pandemie anzuwenden
und deswegen brauchen wir zusätzliche
fristen beispielsweise im paragrafen 5
nicht weil wir alles auf die grundlage
der feststellung einer epidemischen lage
nationaler tragweite stützen das haben
wir am 25 märz gemacht das haben wir am
november gemacht und wir sagen jetzt
dass diese regelungen auslaufen wenn der
bundestag nicht innerhalb von drei
monaten die fortgeltung der all der
epidemischen lage beschließt und das
heißt maximal drei monate
das kann natürlich auch kürzer sein und
es ist auch überhaupt kein problem weil
sie haben ja vollkommen recht werden
nicht nur in der letzten sitzungswoche
10 debatten zum coup 19 gehabt werden
diese woche 13 debatten zu kurve 19
gehabt wir können es jedes mal
feststellen
das ist keine große leistung für unser
haus das kriegen wir hin und lassen sie
mich zuletzt noch auf das thema der impf
ziele und der imf prioritäten hinweisen
ich finde es total erstaunlich wie hier
der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts bemüht wird
mit seinen interview-äußerungen die wir
absolut teilen die wir beherzigen und
die wir mit diesem gesetzentwurf
umsetzen
natürlich artikel 80 des grundgesetzes
verlangt von uns dass wir die
wesentlichen grundentscheidungen hier im
parlament treffen das tun wir
wir haben das schon getan im paragrafen
20 des sgb fünf wir übersetzen das jetzt
mit einer zwillings vorschrift in den
paragrafen 20 absatz 2a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
und damit schaffen wir den rahmen den
stabilen rechtlichen rahmen
auf dessen grundlage dann die regierung
ausformuliert und ausbuchstabiert
weitere maßnahmen machen kann
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
klassen fall stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unionsfraktion hatte
hier gleich mit zwei zwischenfragen zu
tun einmal von gesine lötzsch aus der
linksfraktion und manuela rottmann von
den grünen und da hat man gesehen wie
parlament reich sein sollte ein
aufeinanderzugehen ein austauschen von
argumenten und aber trotzdem auch
einander zuhören und sich unter
umständen sogar auch aufeinander
zubewegen ulrich immer ist der nächste
redner half die fraktion
man gesteht die bundesregierung endlich
einmal ein dass sie nicht nur corona
versorgt hat dieser gesetzentwurf ist
ein weiterer stein in einem haus das auf
einem guten fundament ohne ausreichende
wissenschaftliche begründung errichtet
wurde
wir sagen beenden sie diesen lockdown
geben sie der bevölkerung ihre
grundrechte zurück die whu gab am 13
januar 21 die informationen heraus dass
eine positiv getestete personen ohne
symptome nicht infektiös ist bei
richtiger anwendung dieser empfehlung
haben wir möglicherweise keine pandemie
und ohne jede wissenschaftliche
grundlage ist auch die wahllose inzidenz
grenze der bundesregierung von erst 50
jetzt 35
warum nicht 13 oder 62 5 gestern haben
wir in diesem haus hier eine stunde eine
aktuelle stunde zur meinungsfreiheit
geführt sie alle beteten unisono dass
diese gegeben ist
sie ist es nicht gestern vordere
bayerische ministerpräsident auf
professor weil sich dieser erlaubt hat
kritik an den corinna maßnahmen zu
äußern
das ist bei weitem kein einzelfall dass
personen die die regierung kritisieren
raptor enthoben werden soviel zur
forschungs- und meinungsfreiheit in
diesem land wir haben angesichts der
zustände und unserem land kein recht
andere länder bezüglich ihrer demokratie
zu kritisieren und länder wie schweden
die ukraine und russland haben gezeigt
wie man mit dieser krankheit umgehen
kann
eine sachliche gesellschaftlichen
wirtschaftlich verträgliche lösung ohne
die gefährdung von 0 0 in gruppen
bestand auch in deutschland seit beginn
des ausbruchs
inzwischen sind wir einem punkt
angelangt an dem wir eine moralische
entscheidung treffen müssen opfern wir
das wohl vieler für den schutz weniger
oder besser ist es gerechtfertigt die
grundrechte zu beschneiden existenzen zu
vernichten und das soziale gefüge zu
zerstören um einen hundertprozentigen
schutz der bevölkerung zu erreichen
die bundesregierung nahm und nimmt denn
anders kann diese fortschreibung durch
den vorgelegten gesetzesentwurf nicht
verstanden werden
die verursachten kollateralschäden ihrer
politik einfach finden durch sie stiegen
die depression häusliche gewalt die
selbstmordrate um das zehn bis
zwanzigfache
durch sie werden nachdem die
insolvenzantrags sperre ende märz
aufgelöst wird tausende von existenzen
vernichtet werden durch sie sprechen
bildungsexperten bereits von einer
verlorenen generation von schülern durch
sie wurden familien gespalten verstauben
menschen ohne von ihren angehörigen
lippen zu sagen und das alles durch eine
nicht ausreichende wissenschaftliche
begründung und deshalb bot die auf die
schon lange den einsatz einer ständigen
kommission von wissenschaftlern die
epidemische lage betrachten allerdings
und hier möchte ich frau marx
widersprechen nicht nur aus wissenschaft
und der leopoldina sondern auch für den
wissenschaften und die eine kritische
meinung haben
wissenschaft lebt von kontroversen
austausch nur durch eine solche
kommission bekommen wir hier im hohen
haus die daten auf denen wir unsere
entscheidungen fraktionsübergreifend
treffen können
vielen dank
[Applaus]
jetzt habe ich das wort kollegen direkt
wie sehr es bei der politik wie sie ist
einer der stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden der spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind
sicherlich nach wie vor in einer sehr
herausfordernden situation die immer
noch einen verantwortlichen umgang mit
der aktuellen corona pandemie erfordert
wir müssen einfach feststellen dass die
lage nach wie vor sehr volatil ist wir
sehen das gerade wenn wir den blick ins
nachbarland tschechien richten bei uns
sehen dort warum es auch richtig ist
aktuell zu reagieren kurzfristig
situativ zu reagieren
und gerade hier auch ab dem wochenende
stationären grenzkontrollen möglich zu
machen um diese virus pandemie auch
weiter einzudämmen nichtsdestotrotz
sehen wir auch licht am ende des tunnels
wir sehen dass die zahlen langsam
herunter gehen wir wünschen uns durchaus
mehr
aber wir sehen auch dass das impfen
durchaus voranschreitet und wir dadurch
auch möglichkeiten haben andere
perspektiven den bürgerinnen und bürgern
auch aufzuzeigen es ist aber ich habe
das angesprochen nach wie vor
herausfordernd und darum ist es richtig
den rechtsrahmen die verlängerung der
epidemischen lage heute auf den weg zu
bringen es ist notwendig und dieser
rechtsrahmen
mal findet eine abwägung letztendlich
auf der einen seite in der situativen
reaktion in dem erlass auch von
verordnungen wie es möglich machen immer
wieder zu reagieren und auch schnell zu
reagieren und das ist auch richtig sie
ist aber nur möglich weil der deutsche
bundestag hierüber entscheidet und der
deutsche bundestag diese epidemische
lage auch verlängert und das ist richtig
und ich bin manchmal überrascht wenn ich
die debatten in dieser woche hier auch
verfolgt habe dass diejenigen die am
lautesten die beteiligungsrechte des
bundestages einfordern die am lautesten
deutlich machen wie wichtig ist dass der
bundestag sich damit beschäftigt und
wenn er dann entscheidet wie christian
lindner heute morgen wieder durch
abwesenheit glänzen das kann ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht nachvollziehen
und da kann ich auch liebe kollegen der
fdp
nur darüber den kopf schütteln die
verlängerung der epidemischen lage ist
ein rechtsrahmen
sie führt nicht dazu dass alles
automatisch verlängert wird bis in den
sankt nimmerleinstag nein sie macht es
genauso erforderlich und übrigens auch
möglich dass wir über intelligente
öffnungs konzepte regionale
differenzierungen diskutieren und auch
die notwendige debatte führen in den
nächsten wochen was kann man wie in
welcher form und auch wann wieder öffnen
und zu lassen das ist eine
erwartungshaltung die die bürgerinnen
und bürger zu recht an uns haben und
dieser herausforderung müssen wir uns
auch annehmen und hier diese debatte
auch aus meiner sicht sehr sachlich
führen
ich bin allerdings wenn ich das sagen
darf frau schulz asche etwas irritiert
gewesen von ihrer rede sie haben
gesprochen dass es autoritäre ansagen
der bundesregierung gibt die aus ihrer
sicht ich will es mal zusammenfassen
nicht verhältnismäßig sind ich glaube es
gab eine entscheidung des
verwaltungsgerichtshofs mannheim in
dieser woche wurde die baden
württembergische landesregierung die von
den grünen geführt wird zurechtgewiesen
ist im hinblick auf die ausgangs
beschränkungen wie man entsprechende
verordnungen nicht er lasst sie haben in
baden württemberg deutlich gezeigt dass
sie sich nicht an recht und gesetz im
hinblick auf den 28 a
infektionsschutzgesetz gehalten haben
und da muss ich ganz deutlich sagen das
ist nicht das wie wir uns
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen vorgestellt
haben die sind definitiv da in die
falsche richtung gegangen hätten sie ein
film frage der königin schulsaal sehr
gerne herr kollege
ich weiß nicht ob sie mir wirklich gut
zugehört haben
der zusammenhang in dem ich da von den
autoritären ansagen besprochen habe
bezüglich auffällt die treffen der
bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten und den daraus
folgenden anordnungen die nicht vom
parlament legitimiert sind und von daher
bitte ich sie das zur kenntnis zu nehmen
und war da jetzt auch ihre fraktion ja
daran beteiligt ist dagegen
gesetzentwurf zur epidemischen lage auch
weiterzuentwickeln darauf rücksicht zu
nehmen und dafür zu sorgen dass wir
gemeinsam als demokratische fraktion in
diesem fall
moment hier zu verbesserungen kommen ich
würde ihnen empfehlen das nicht für
einfache wahlkampf aktionen zu nutzen
sondern tatsächlich zuzuhören denn ihr
geht es um eine ernste sache und die ist
die epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite liebe kollegin ich bin
wirklich sehr dankbar für die
zwischenfrage weil die mir möglich macht
noch mal einiges klarzustellen ich habe
manchmal den eindruck wenn sie das jetzt
auch noch mal sagen und was mich
ehrlicherweise noch einmal bestätigt
dass sie manchmal den eindruck versuchen
wir zu vermitteln dass sie da gar nicht
mit am tisch sitzen
dass sie da gar nichts mit zu tun haben
ihr grüner ministerpräsident sitzt in
sämtlichen runden mit dabei und ich muss
auch mal ganz klar sagen wenn sie dann
letztendlich die landtage noch mit rein
nehmen die landtage mit den weg nicht
vor hasselmann es tut manchmal weh wenn
man den spiegel vorgehalten kriegt aber
sie haben regierungsverantwortung in elf
bundesländern und sie können sich nicht
hinstellen und sagen sie hätten mit der
ganzen sache nichts zu tun das
funktioniert nicht vor schulz-asche ich
muss ihnen auch sagen wenn sie das sagen
mit den landtagen und da sind sie gerade
nochmal eingegangen dann wundert es mich
nicht schon wenn wir im weiteren
verfahren jetzt in die beratungen
einsteigen warum ich von ihnen dann auch
nichts höre dass wir darüber nachdenken
müssen den 28 absatz 7 uns auch
anzuschauen
der 28 87 sagt nämlich dass landtage die
fortgeltung der epidemischen lage
unbefristet beschließen können ich bin
sehr dafür dass dieses auch nur
befristet erfolgt hier höre ich von
ihnen zum beispiel gar nichts an dem
punkt dann bin ich sehr gespannt wie sie
sich in die laufenden beratungen
letztendlich auch einbringen ich kann
nur sagen das was der
verwaltungsgerichtshof in mannheim
entschieden hat aufgrund ist 28a den wir
als koalitionsfraktionen auf den weg
gebracht haben das war richtig und hat
gezeigt dass sie nicht verstanden haben
wie man das angemessen gemacht haben
müsste und die kritik müssen sie sich
heute hier auch gefallen dass
herr kollege diese auch die kollegen
dort würde gerade noch eine
zwischenfrage stellen sehr gerne ja ich
habe das vermutet ich habe jetzt die
nächste zwischenfrage tief werden ihre
rede zu lassen
herr kollege wieso ich kenne den 28 a
sehr gut denn vielleicht erinnern sie
sich daran dass wir grüne daran intensiv
mitgearbeitet haben
ergo lese wiese das was mir ein bisschen
sorgen macht bei der spd ist dass sie in
einer debatte um ein gesetz hier im
deutschen bundestag nichts mehr anderes
einfällt als auf landesregierungen zu
verweisen die sind nun nicht dafür
zuständig die sind nun nicht dafür
zuständig die gesetzlichen grundlagen zu
schaffen sondern das sind wir hier und
dann will ich ihnen auch einen dritten
hinweis geben
in baden württemberg ist der landtag an
der entscheidung über die verordnung und
beteiligt das ist ein wesentlicher
unterschied
[Applaus]
kollegen ohne mikrofon und sie antwortet
der kollege sich noch eine weitere
zwischenfrage haben sie dürfen gerne
okay gut dass es das ist nicht der fall
frage vor ob man ihnen gerade ein
bisschen irritiert darüber dass sie
sagen dass sozusagen die verlängerung
der epidemischen lage die letztendlich
die anwendbarkeit des 5 des 28 möglich
macht aufgrund dessen und aufgrund
dessen entscheidungen in der mpk ergehen
aufgrund dessen corona schutzverordnung
der länder auch erlassen werden dass sie
suggerieren dass da gar nichts mit den
landesregierungen mit zu tun ist ich
meine nicht das tut mir leid aber sie
haben letztendlich ich sage das noch mal
in elf landesregierungen regiere sie mit
und sie habe an einigen
landesregierungen und das zeigt sich
exemplarisch in baden württemberg gerade
maßnahmen erlassen die nicht recht und
gesetz entsprechend und darum haben sie
dafür auch eine niederlage vor dem
verwaltungsgerichtshof in mannheim
bekommen weil sie nicht angemessen
regelung getroffen haben und das müssen
sie sich heute hier auch anhört ich kann
nichts dafür dass ihnen das nicht
gefällt dass sie sich in baden
württemberg nicht an recht und gesetz
gehalten haben und das muss man hier
nochmal ausführt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich komme
zurück da ich gerade trotz zwischenrufen
von frau hoss will man die aber keine
frage mehr zu stellen scheint sondern
sich auf zwischenrufe beschränkt gerne
noch einmal zurückkommen für das weitere
verfahren ist es wichtig und da will ich
an hilde mattheis anknüpfen
dass wir es für gut und richtig halten
an dem bundesgesundheitsminister dass
wir die evaluierung aufgenommen haben
wir wissen aber auch dass evaluierungen
die an keine fristen geknüpft sind sehr
oft auch in schreibtischschubladen
durchaus manchmal verschwinden darum ist
es durchaus richtig auch diese
evaluierung und damit auch das
infektionsschutzgesetz einer befristung
zuzuführen und hier glaube ich müssen
wir im verfahren noch einmal sehr genau
darüber diskutieren und auch wie wir
weiter die diskussion führen können über
vorhersehbarkeit über stufen pläne hier
gibt es auch möglichkeiten im 28 absatz
3 sich etwas genauer noch mal damit zu
beschäftigen
ich freue mich jedenfalls auf die
parlamentarischen beratungen mit blick
auf die zwischenfragen der grünen
scheint dass der lebhaft zu werden
vielen dank
rund um das mal gleich aufzunehmen was
der krise der stellvertretende
vorsitzende der spd-fraktion da gerade
gesagt hat der bundestag streitet um ein
gesetzentwurf der koalition zur
fortgeltung der epidemischen lage aber
auch das muss man sagen es ist ein
streit der angenehmeren art ohne schärfe
ohne unterstellungen sondern tatsächlich
an der sache orientiert wieland
schinnenburg ist der nächste redner aus
der fdp-fraktion kommt er zu viel
der reihe nach das erste de steht für
demokratien der gesetzentwurf wird dazu
führen dass der deutsche bundestag an
thema corona nur noch ein abnickorgan
ist wir dürfen dann alle drei modelle
beschließen ja die epidemische lage
besteht noch und der rest wird wirklich
verordnung geregelt meine damen und
herren das macht die fdp nicht mit
das zweite d steht für dankbarkeit ganz
oft in debatten die haben wir darüber
gesprochen wie viele menschen im gesetz
wesen wir dankbar sein sollten
und viele von denen lassen sie jetzt im
regen stehen fangen wir an mit den
niedergelassenen ärzten
sie wissen ganz genau dass wir den hier
ist den ärzten zu verdanken haben dass
unser gesundheitssystem nicht
zusammengebrochen ist weil sie
mindestens drei viertel der patienten
behandeln so dass die gar nicht erst ins
krankenhaus kommen und die krankenhäuser
auch gar nicht überlassen können wir
sind gegen die da ist und ärzten zu
großem dank verpflichtet meine damen und
herren
sie hatten sie hatten vor einem jahr die
richtige konsequenz gezogen indem sie
die niedersten den ärzten 90 prozent des
honorars abgesichert haben
diese vorschrift läuft aus und sie
verlängern sie nicht mal die haben die
herren sie lassen den hessen der ärzten
allein das machen wir als fdp auch nicht
mit meine damen und herren die zweite
gruppe dies zu denken gibt sind die
menschen die in der pflege arbeit ich
denke da sowohl die professionelle
pflege einrichtungen als auch an die
pflegenden angehörigen jeder weiß dass
diese an der grenze ihrer belastbarkeit
für uns alle arbeit nicht nur viel zu
pflegen und für uns allen helfen sie
auch die lassen sie alleine
bisher war es so dass alle winde einen
namen von pflegeeinrichtungen abgedeckt
werden das ändern sie jetzt nur in
bestimmten fällen werden die noch
abgesetzt oder abgesichert und der
zweite punkt die vierte
pflegehilfsmittel der ein bisschen bis
zu 40 euro erstattet im entwurf stand
drin ursprünglich es wird auf 60 euro
erhöht das haben sie gestrichen man
damit jedoch insofern eine skandalöse
genauso reilly auch wir als fdp nicht
mitmachen meine damen und herren
der dritte punkt der dritte punkt sind
weitere gruppen physiotherapeuten
logopäden und hebammen kriegen keine
hygiene pauschale zahnärzte werden auf
eine liquiditätshilfe reduziert und die
home care kriegen erst gar nichts meine
damen und herren so geht man nicht mit
den menschen um den wie so viel
verdanken
kurz gesagt erst gab es von ihnen warme
worte und jetzt gibt's die kalte
schulter
ja und dann ist da noch das dritte die
das dritte de steht für droge
sie sind der droge der macht vor
sie können es nicht ertragen das
parlament mitreden soll wir sollen doch
alle drei monate was zu stehen meine
damen und herren das macht die fdp als
rechtsstaatspartei nicht mit da können
sie sicher sein meine damen und herren
es bleibt hier als fdp werden uns weiter
für die menschen engagieren dem
gesundheitswesen an der grenze
möglichkeit arbeiten die müssen die im
stich gelassen werden denen müssen wir
helfen vielen dank meine damen und
herren
wieland schinnenburg war das aus der fdp
fraktion in der debatte zur fortgeltung
der epidemischen lage sie sehen meine
damen und herren wir weisen schon auf
eine pressekonferenz mit dem
bundesgesundheitsminister hin wir sind
nicht ganz sicher ob er diese debatte
vor ende dieser debatte verlassen wird
das versuchen wir mal zwischenzeitlich
rauszukriegen
deswegen kann es sein dass sich diese
bundespressekonferenz die in der regel
pünktlich ist und zwar sehr pünktlich
aber heute ausnahmsweise etwas später
beginnt denn sie wissen es gibt auch
eine enorme debatte über die rolle des
parlaments bei entscheidungen rund um
die korona pandemie wir werden uns mal
schlau machen und sie dann auf den stand
der dinge bringen ein 2 1 haben wir
georg nüßlein zudem stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion
expertenrat einsetzen will für eine
epidemie dieses angabegemäß gar nicht
gibt aber jedenfalls sind wir uns einig
dass wir leider und wider erwarten nach
über einem jahr eben nicht durch sind
mit dem thema und deshalb debattieren
wir heute so heftig über etwas was
zentral ist nämlich einen beschluss für
die fortgeltung der epidemischen lage
nationaler tragweite der eigentlich das
zentrale elemente parlamentarischen
mitwirkung bei der pandemie bekämpfen
und er ist meine damen und herren die
grundlage für das handeln der exekutive
die da besonders gefordert ist aber sie
ist natürlich auch der rahmen die
beschränkung sowie was gerade
beispielsweise vom kollegen diese gehört
haben die beschränkung für das was der
exekutive an der stelle kann
wir haben im rückblick alle miteinander
auch das parlament ganz bewusst
verantwortung wahrgenommen und ich
glaube dass auch der große tag hier
überzeugung ist dass der noch immer
laufende lockdown richtig und wichtig
war und zu den ergebnissen führt über
momentan in den zahlen sind sagte es
wenn man dann formuliert man deutschland
kommt relativ gut durch die pandemie und
dass man das nicht unkritisch sagen auch
das sage ich da sehe ich das zu hause
wie der kollege frei der das mit blick
auf die opposition und die kritik gesagt
hat wir haben zur kenntnis nehmen müssen
dass die vorhalte finanzhilfen nicht so
zu den menschen gekommen sind wie das
notwendig war oder um es in den worten
von hand stolz zu sagen die banker hatte
ladehemmung an der stelle und deshalb
ideal miteinander übrigens opposition
wie die regierung tragenden fraktionen
darauf gedrängt dass sich das in der
überbrückungshilfe 3 jetzt ändert ich
habe auch gelernt dass deutschland als
land der einzelfallgerechtigkeit ohne
bürokratie nicht kann und deshalb bin
ich sehr vorsichtig bei dem was hier
gelegentlich vorgetragen wird zum thema
im priorisierung so wie sie sich das
vorstellen nämlich im klein-klein das
zureden möglichst mit
bundestagsbeschluss kommen wir am
schluss in einem maße dass uns jede
flexibilität geben ein beispiel bei mir
im wahlkreis wurde
anders als die priorisierung das vor ca
ein behindertenheim durchgeimpft die
werden später dran gewesen nach der
reihenfolge aber es ist ein
infektionsherd und auch das gibt unserem
verordnung des ministers an der stelle
her dass entsprechend zu machen um hier
wirklich auch richtig und zielführend
vor ort damit umzugehen
wir brauchen diese flexibilität und wir
brauchen die auch bei der frage wie geht
es in den nächsten tagen in den nächsten
wochen weiter mit dem blog da wir müssen
hier sehr genau abwägen zwischen
gesundheitsschutz auf der einen seite
und der stabilität der ökonomische mit
gesellschaftlichen stabilität unseres
landes auf der anderen seite das ergibt
sich aus unserem grundgesetz aber eben
auch unmittelbar aus dem ja hier im haus
beschlossener 28 jahre
infektionsschutzgesetz der regierte mich
beispielsweise sehr schlüssig dass dann
wenn die inzidenz zahlen solide unter 50
sind das dann ein pauschaler umfassender
lockdown nicht mehr möglich ist auch das
haben wir doch letztendlich entsprechend
geredet und er gibt vor dass wir
differenzierungen nach regionen und
lebensbereichen machen müssen und das
ist mir ein ganz besonderes anliegen
dass wir zügig an diesem punkt kommt
lobt kann ist eine maßnahme um eine
welle zu brechen
doch meine damen und herren was kommt
danach ja jeder der heute über
lockerungen spricht leben wird
unterstellt es ging ihm leichtfertig
darum irgendwie wieder zu öffnen und
normales leben zu spielen nein es geht
doch um die frage wie gehen wir nach dem
log haben was ja irgendwann mal relevant
wird mit dieser thematik um und da
brauchen wir zusätzlich konzepte da ist
auf der einen seite beschlossen dass er
das auto der ministerpräsidenten der
staatskanzlei arbeitet dann sicherlich
auch unsere aufgabe hier im deutschen
bundestag darüber zu diskutieren und
damit umzugehen impfen
wie machen wir das medikamente da
passiert mir noch zu wenig da was wir
nun stärker in die richtung gehen dass
nach voranzubringen aber auch darüber
traurig auf den
bundesgesundheitsminister dass er das
thema im blick hat und ist testen
nachdem wir gesehen haben dass das aus
irgendwelchen gründen bei den
altenheimen nicht so geklappt hat wie
wir es uns vorgestellt haben müssen wir
noch stärker darauf dringen dass wir in
der fläche
festen dafür sorge tragen dass wir die
identifizieren können die tatsächlich
angesteckt sind und das ist für mich
dann auch wichtig schlüsse zu ziehen
denn meine damen und herren wir brauchen
auch einen datenschutz
am schluss der dass die gesundheitsdaten
des einzelnen schützt aber verhindert
doch in gottes namen nicht die forschung
und verhindern wir um gottes namen nicht
die möglichkeit auch hier in der breite
schutz für die menschen zu erwirken wir
wissen noch zu wenig zum beispiel über
ansteckungswege und das musste ich meine
damen und herren zügig ändern dass der
deutsche bundestag das thema offen
diskutiert dass schlaf die lügen die
hier versuchen etwas anders da zu stehen
und ihre eigene rolle übrigens als
opposition bei der gelegenheit
kleinreden wiener kindern sagt jochim
nüßlein einer der stellvertretenden
vorsitzenden der unionsfraktion und
unüberhörbar mitglied der csu
landesgruppe er war auch der drittletzte
redner in dieser ersten beratung eines
gesetzentwurfs der koalitionsfraktionen
zur fortgeltung der epidemischen lage in
der es aber auch etwa um die im
verordnung geht oder um auch um eine
evaluierung der entscheidungs und
regelungs wege der bisherigen rundum
corona edgar franke ist der vorletzte
redner und mitglied der spd fraktion und
der bundesgesundheitsminister ist nach
wie vor im plenum alle einer meinung
aber ich sage auch außergewöhnliche
zeiten erfordern außergewöhnliche
maßnahmen und die pandemie macht es
leider macht leider maßnahmen notwendig
die unsere freiheitsrechte massiv
einschränken aber ich sage auch auch in
richtung von afd
das recht auf leben das recht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit geht
grundsätzlich alle rechten unter
rechtsordnung vor da muss man
ausdrücklich betonen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
und und diese rechte diese rechte gelten
ja in einem rechtsstaat nicht
unbeschränkt denn der grundrechts
vorgang vorrang gilt nur wenn großer
maßnahmen auch verhältnismäßig sind so
diese recht schranke wenn sie so wollen
haben wir ja ich hoffe sehr ich hoffe
sehr dass diese einschränkungen und wir
hoffen dass alle schrittweise aufheben
können wir alle wollen wieder ins
stadion wir alle wollen wieder ins
restaurant wir alle wollen wieder kultur
genießen
wir freuen uns war das die friseure
wieder aufmachen das bringt mir
persönlich allerdings nicht so viel das
muss ich auch sagen meine sehr verehrten
daten mit wir wollen verwandte wir
wollen gute freunde wieder umarmen und
leider ist es noch nicht so weit und
gerade familien familien mit kleinen
kindern wissen wie hart das ist dass man
jetzt geduld noch braucht aber neben
geduld brauchen wir auch verlässlichkeit
verlässlichkeit verlässlichkeit wenn es
darum geht wer wann geimpfte wir haben
eine priorisierung konkrete süd
regierung im gesetz dh es muss
nachvollziehbar sein
ja warum gewisse teile der bevölkerung
früher oder später geimpft werden ein
gutes beispiel sind schulen und kitas
einerseits wollen wir wieder öffnen
andererseits wird dort kaum jemand bis
jetzt kämpft und das ist sicherlich ein
problem das muss man auch ganz klar
sagen deswegen sollten wir nochmals
überprüfen ob kinder
ob lehrer ob es ihr nicht früher
gefährden könnten wir müssen gucken wie
wir das mit der einstieg stiko
empfehlung vereinbar machen können
offene offene schulen offene kitas sind
nicht nur für kinder sondern familien
absolut notwendig meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren auch hier muss
gesundheit an erster stelle stehen
gerade wenn wir mutationen nachweisen
auch bei uns in deutschland
wir brauchen jetzt zum zweiten
verlässlichkeit auch bei den rechtlichen
rahmen
heute haben wir im detail ja schon das
gesetz debattiert und es wird für mehr
rechtliche verlässlichkeit sorgen es
erlaubt nämlich den regierungen und dem
bund massnahmen zu treffen aber wir
stellen eben gerade kein blankoscheck
aus weder für minister sparen wird ein
blankoscheck ausgestellt noch für die
regierung der bundestag hat immer das
letzte wort und der 28 a
da hat eine ausstellung wird regelung
ich glaube dass eine rechtsstaatliche
regelung es ist eine gute regelung und
ist eine regelung die man nachvollziehen
kann meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren
außerdem ohne einen bundestagsbeschluss
laufen alle regelungen auch die
verordnung automatisch aus nach drei
monaten laufen die aus also bei den
wichtigen entscheidungen führt kein weg
am bundestag vorbei ist auch gut so und
dann damit ist in dem primat ist ja der
bundesverfassungsgerichtspräsident
mehrmals angesprochen werden alle
wichtigen entscheidungen müssen eine
demokratie im parlament getroffen werden
und den tragen wir mit diesem gesetz
auch rechnungen auch das muss man
ausdrücklich sagen und meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren seit einem
jahr müssen wir mit corona leben das
verlangt wirklich von uns allen ab und
wir sind ja im wahlkreis unterwegs wir
wissen was das bei den menschen bei den
familien bewirkt deshalb brauchen wir
sicherlich auch für unsere gesellschaft
eine klare perspektive
wir brauchen auch eine klare strategie
das muss man auch ganz sagen weil wir
müssen schrittweise zur normalität
zurückkehren nur das gibt hoffnung und
das schafft vertrauen
die kanzlerin sagt immer das licht am
ende des tunnels und nur mit vertrauen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
kommen wir gemeinsam aus dieser pandemie
für uns sozialdemokraten gilt gelebte
solidarität ist hierbei das wirksamste
mittel ist angela franke für die
spd-fraktion hier wird gleich noch ein
redner kommen wir wechseln aber die
schauplätze der bundestag diskutiert
über eine reihe von maßnahmen die mit
der korrekten 19 bekämpfung zu tun haben
bzw mit hilfen für familien oder
betriebe etwa in der gastronomie das wo
auch vor dem hintergrund von kritik aus
der opposition das parlament diskutieren
zu wenig über all diese maßnahmen und
beschlüsse und die
entscheidungsspielräume der regierung
seien zu groß